in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Daniel
and Tracy are Weathers hey guys how are
you
well how are you better than I deserve
welcome welcome where y'all from
we're from Allentown Pennsylvania Oh fun
very cool well good to have you thanks
for joining us
so you're here to do your debt-free
screen we are it's a long travel to do
that 12 hours and 37 minutes in the car
whoa
not not that anybody was counting with
small kids in the car yeah
don't know anybody like that but yeah
very cool so how much debt of you guys
paid off
we paid off two hundred and seventeen
thousand dollars whoa and how long did
that take thirty nine months Wow and
your range of income during that four
years plus um we started just under two
hundred and then went up from there with
a couple job changes and raises from
there Wow very cool so what do you guys
do for a living I'm in HR systems I work
for a specialty chemicals company right
outside of Wilmington Delaware mm-hmm
and I'm a surgical physician assistant
ah very cool so you're obviously doing
very well congratulations thank you
great huge income so what kind of debt
was this this was our home you've paid
off your house we did you're not old
enough to have a paid-for house no we're
not thank you very weird you're so weird
I'm looking at weird people yeah how old
are you our average age is 33 well that
was a great answer I like it it's fun
very good 33 years old average and the
house is paid for
what's this house worth it's worth about
$400,000 Wow congratulations thank you
and I mean you guys are 33 years old you
have a paid-for house and you make 200
plus a year you're not gonna do anything
but become very very wealthy and become
very very very generous in the process
this is where you are man this is
incredible it's got to feel awesome how
does it feel to have a paid-for house
it's I can't even describe it it's
awesome I mean thankfully the boys cut
the yard so I don't have to do that but
the yard feels great you know I mean
it's just it's ours and there's so much
we
can do now where we don't have to send
that mortgage payment and our mortgage
payment was big I mean it was not that
big but are the payments are setting in
we're really big oh yeah you're saying
jokes yeah that's a lot about not
writing those taxes oh yeah you got all
kinds of room in this budget now to do
all kinds of cool stuff so what happened
thirty nine months ago that made you
guys at 30 years old decide you're gonna
do this so Tracy was raised on the
kool-aid and really I had never been a
spender very much a saver in the past
but I really didn't have a mechanism to
to watch my budget or know where every
dollar was going and I met Tracy and I
know that very often you say that people
have marriage reform or you know there's
there's help in a marriage when they go
on to your plan and start living that
but for me it was seeing her passion
about your plan and I mean we would
spend and this tells you how much you
know nerds we are but we would spend
hours on the phone at night talking
about our dreams and what we would end
up doing once we had our mortgage paid
off and and so 39 months ago is when we
got married
Oh from there we took off so the plan
was all lined up on the runway you just
had to take off and do it exactly
everything was all mapped out that the
travel plans were in place you just had
to execute yes oh wow that's neat so we
could do these two great incomes
combined you just start punching the
thing relentlessly and it's gone that's
very very cool so what do you mean by
raised on the kool-aid Tracy what's he
talking about well my dad was doing the
Dave Ramsey plan before it was really
the Dave Ramsey plan yeah so he's been
doing this for a long time my parents
built the home I grew up in with no debt
and they just didn't finish you know
didn't finish the base until they had
the money didn't do anything so had the
money so they never had any debt so for
me it was not an option
you know they sent me to school
debt-free and so I got out and started
dating Daan we were dating for maybe
like three or four months and I said I
really like you you need to read this
book or else you know
and so a little bit of consumer debt and
more money than that in the bank and so
you know sold this motorcycle and wrote
some checks and was debt-free which
didn't matter to me as much as him
getting on board with this is the way
we're gonna live our life once we're
married exactly yeah we're gonna be what
this is the future so you need to look
at it carefully she was so passionate
about it that she made me a complete
believer all right very cool that's very
neat I love it well congratulations you
too
so what do you tell people the secret to
getting out of that house and everything
is by the time you're 33 years old I
think there's two keys the first one is
no matter how old you are what your
income is that you have to decide that
you're gonna live within your means
you're never gonna buy anything you
can't afford you're never gonna spend
any money that you don't have because
it's really easy in America to do that
but if you choose to never do that you
will always be able to pay off debt you
will always be able to make progress
save and invest and send your kids to
college debt-free you can do any of
those things if you just don't spend any
money that you don't have and you live
on whatever your income is and the
second thing is marrying someone or
being in a marriage with someone who is
on board and it's on the same team as
you because if you're both pulling in
the same direction you are
infinitesimally stronger than if you're
going by yourself amen well said what
about you Dan what do you think I think
one of the keys is to find what
motivates you I think for every person
that's different whether it's you know
having their fully funded emergency fund
paying for their entire mortgage being
completely debt free or you know owning
that big bass boat
I think everybody's got that motivating
factor and that they need to focus on it
frequently not just thinking about oh
you know I have this budget I've gotta
stick to but reminding yourself what
motivates you and I think that's really
what helps get it through along with
like she said you know having that life
partner that's there and will stick with
you and support you through anything
amen
well good job you guys very very well
done what was the hardest part of
getting out of debt for you guys I think
probably the hardest part was that we
would say no a lot
even though we had a great income we
were really really sticklers about
putting as much as possible every month
on the mortgage and so even though we
quote-unquote had the money we didn't
have the money to spend on going out to
eat we had the money to spend on paying
off the mortgage so there was a in the
spring we were planning on going to a
charity event at the school I graduated
from to support the scholarship fund
that put me through college so something
we really wanted to do and the car
needed new tires or one blew out or
something happened and there wasn't
enough room in the budget to do this
$400 charity event and fix the car and
so I had to call and cancel our
reservation I had to tell all the
friends we were planning on going with
we can't afford to do this this month
and so and they're all looking at us
like is that really true I think they
knew you know I said we can't afford to
do this this month and we're paying off
our mortgage like so I mean we had money
I could have pulled it out of the money
and going to pay off the mortgage and
they just said no we're not willing and
we said no a lot to a lot of different
things and so you know knowing that it
was there but it was being used for
something that next year we'll go next
year we're putting money in you know
I'll take them next year to do whatever
we want so you know but saying no to a
lot of stuff for a couple years you know
what's weird is when you don't do
something like that
that was emotional for you to make that
decision but then when you get six
months other side of it you're going
crap that wasn't anything like whoopee I
just miss that I missed a bad chicken
dinner another rubber rubber caterer
chicken you know it's you know you look
at you go I will go make sure that what
you're deciding and you're going or
you're gonna miss the bachelorette party
yeah yeah you have these things and then
you know when you get like old like me
you look back yeah I don't remember any
of them right it's just I don't remember
any of that all I don't remember is
winning because I did do it so good for
you guys
congratulations very proud of you now
you brought the kiddos you did and what
are the ages of names
Zachary is 13 cooper is 11 Colby's 18
months and we have one coming in
February all right very cool anyways
today yeah look at that that's great so
you guys ought to be watching this on
YouTube right now you could see all of
this happening see or watching it on the
Dave Ramsey show channel either one all
right Daniel and Tracy
Zachary Cooper and Colby ready Allentown
Pennsylvania
two hundred and seventeen thousand
dollars paid off in 39 months making two
hundred plus count it down let's hear a
debt free scream ready yeah three two
one
that's how it's done folks that's how
it's done this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show you can do this you know that
really is a message whether you've got
two hundred seventy thousand dollars in
student loan debt or twenty seven
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a $500,000 in
common